IN MYANMAR.
KILLEDCEE GOVERNMEIV BEEN
E SINCE GAINING
IT DID
MILITARY SEID CONTROL BACKW ANT
T TOOCRACY.
SAKIH THIS
EXCLUSIVE .eporteG JOURNE EVENT
A REBEN G TH
UPRISINGINOU
MILITARYUNTA.
SOME 200 VOLUNTEERS HAVE COMSEEI
WANT TO FIGHA REGIME POWER IN FD
BRUTALLY DASHE
DEHE
EYNG RKERS, MANY STUDENPROTESTED
T KEIN  THIS CAN GIVE US THE PO
>> Reporter: THE INSTRUCTORS ARE
MEMBERS OF THEFRONT, A LONG STA
ALLIANCE WITH MYANMAR'S NATIONA.
THESE ARE ON D OF THEILY GOIO G
DRILL, ALTBOL WEAPONTRE
INTO THE FIGHTREBE BACK
>> THERE ARE MORE 5,0
ORGANIZING ANDG
TRorter: IT REALLY IS L WAR, I'
>> RECT E
NT
LINES.
ED TRAININDANGEROUCONSEQUENCES.
VILLAGE WH TTHE E WOMEN,ND ELDFL
SODSF . B
T MILITARY FOR
ITALITY.
THE CHIN NATIONAL FRT SAIDED 3,P
CAMP
THAT HAVHATEST OF THEIE G HOMEMF
THISS A JU
TRAINING.THROUGH
SHOTGUNSLE AY REAN
ONFLICT CONTINUE
TH DEAD  RISE TOWHNT
Y ST